bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi de
retour d'algérie nicolas sarkozy
reconnaît que la france a commis des
fautes contre les harkis il leur promet
l'hommage de la nation
notre invité ce soir enrico macias le
grand absent de ce voyage présidentiel
bonsoir ya tout à l'heure coup de filet
en france contre le thé à un couple
soupçonné d'avoir tiré sur les gardes
civils espagnols samedi dernier a été
arrêté en lozère le second policier n'a
pas survécu à ses blessures
le lancement du bonus malus écologique
sur les voitures une prime de 200 à 1000
euros est versée dès aujourd'hui pour
l'achat d'un véhicule propre
une taxe de 200 à 2600 euros sera
appliquée aux voitures polluantes la fin
du déni ici dans le procès des
agresseurs de mama galedou à aix en
provence pour la première fois l'un des
mineurs accusés est passé aux aveux il a
reconnu avoir jeté un mouchoir enflammé
dans le bus le projet de fusion anpe
unedic sera présenté demain en conseil
des ministres nous irons en grande
bretagne où le contrôle des chômeurs a
été poussée jusqu'à l'utilisation de
détecteurs de mensonges
enfin français dans l'espace léopold
eyharts 50 ans fait partie de l'équipage
de la navette qui va acheminer demain le
premier laboratoire européen de
recherche à la station spatiale
internationale
on commence donc avec ce qu'il faut bien
appeler les chassés croisés de
l'histoire entre la france et l'algérie
à peine rentré de son voyage où la
question du passé et de la colonisation
a été omniprésente
nicolas sarkozy recevait tout à l'heure
les associations d'anciens combattants
d'afrique du nord et de rapatriés harkis
il a voulu rendre un hommage inédit à
ces derniers engagés dans l'armée
française pendant la guerre pour lutter
contre le fln le président de la
république reconnaît une faute de la
france et promet réparation alexandre
kara philippe turpault
il y à 45 ans que les arts qui attendait
cela
pour la france il s'agit aujourd'hui
d'une question d'honneur
il faut réparer les fautes qui ont été
commises alors à tous les harkis envers
lesquels la france n dette
je dis au nom de la république que la
france leur doit réparation et nicolas
sarkozy d'énumérer une série de mesures
en forme de discrimination positive pour
les enfants de harkis
il va plus loin pour la première fois la
france assume ce drame pour la france
pour moi la cause des arts qui est une
cause sacrée car on ne peut pas les
tenir responsables d'avoir cru dans la
parole de la france si une faute a été
commise
c'est pas par eux c'est par la
collectivité nationale qui leur a
demandé de faire cela et pourtant après
le discours les réactions des harkis
sont mitigés le président sarkozy a de
belles choses de bonnes choses mais nous
attendons de voir
il a parlé de faute mais il n'a pas
parlé de responsabilité de l'état
français
ils étaient près de 200 milles ces
supplétifs de l'armée française pendant
la guerre d'algérie ce qu'on appelait
alors les soldats indigènes au lendemain
des accords d'evian victimes du fln ou
de règlements de comptes
ils seront massacrés par dizaines de
milliers d'autres auront plus de chance
ils sont rapatriés en métropole
aujourd'hui ils seraient près de 400
mille en france issus de ces familles
arty depuis 1987 à intervalles réguliers
l'état a débloqué des aides pour ceux
qui ont désormais le statut d'ancien
combattant
en 2007 leur pension officiel s'élève à
3800 au vert pour ceux qui n'y ont pas
renoncé en échange d'un pécule
ce soir nicolas sarkozy a fait un geste
mais il faudra sans doute encore du
temps pour apaiser près d'un demi-siècle
de souffrance voyons maintenant d'autres
réactions des intéressés
beaucoup d'entre eux reprochent à la
france de les avoir abandonnés sur le
territoire algérien livrés à des
exécutions sommaires les autres ceux qui
ont été admis sur le sol français
estiment souvent avoir été laissé pour
compte
samah soula bruno girodon
un local aveugle à la cité de la
briqueterie le repère des derniers
survivants des harkis partis en
catastrophe en 1962 la même histoire les
mêmes blessures quand il s'agit
d'évoquer leur arrivée dans ce pays
inconnu quitter la france
les camps le froid isolement
l'incompréhension face à un état
français absent le sentiment d'avoir
échappé à la mort pour tomber dans la
misère parce qu'ils ont parlé labrecque
par la france ils ont dû aussi
abandonner leurs familles sont arrivés
ici sans savoir parler français
alors que la colonie française c'est
comme connu ponsard et 135 en gaieté
français en 1962 la famille abdellatif a
choisi de se poser dans un village
reculé de la seule peur des représailles
en kabylie leur père s'était retrouvé à
traduire les discours de propagande de
l'armée française en plus ils ont
souffert dans leur chair ils ont
souffert de privation ils ont été
victimes de non-reconnaissance de grave
que ça plus grave pour eux ce ne sont
pas les indemnisations dérisoire ou
l'absence d'excusés un silence à la
maison nous raccompagne store on ne sait
pas s'il s'agit
ce qu'on sait c'est quand on sort
d'hommes on nous traite d'enfants de
traîtres pour tous
un regret que la reconnaissance arrive
tard elle aurait distille permis à nos
parents de vivre mieux d'alléger le
poids d'un choix qu'ils n'ont pas
toujours nié une image enfin du voyage
de nicolas sarkozy qui s'est achevée par
une visite à l'université de constantine
avec un bain de foule encadrée pour
célébrer une amitié franco algérienne
qui ne va pas de soi à tout le monde
l'aura compris dans son discours le
président de la république a condamné
une nouvelle fois le système colonial
mais sans présenter des excuses
il souhaite une nouvelle ère dans les
relations entre alger et paris avec
comme gage de bonne volonté l'accord de
coopération en matière de nucléaire
civil images signées stéphane guillemot
nous retrouverons enrico macias dans un
court instant nous avons un petit
problème de son en france après
et quatre jours de quatre jours après la
fusillade contre deux gardes civils
espagnols dans les landes la police
pense avoir mis la main sur deux des
membres du commando de letea un couple
espagnol
les vérifications sont en cours dans le
même temps on a appris que le second
garde civile n'a pas survécu à ses
blessures
zine dine boudaoud pascal tous les deux
suspects étaient armés ils ont opposé
aucune résistance aux gendarmes le
couple avait semble-t-il été repérée
bien avant son arrivée dans ce petit
village de lozère
la jeune femme et l'homme se sont
reposés dans cet hôtel avant de
reprendre la route
il voulait se rendre aux puits et ont
été interpellés près de sept arrêts de
bus sont sortis de l'hôtel et se sont
mis sur la nationale pour faire du stop
et à cette occasion et bien on a décidé
avec l'équipe était sur place de les
interpeller ici personne n'a rien
remarqué de suspect dans le comportement
du couple au fort accent espagnol et
adama paris beaucoup le monsieur ne
parle presque pas vous êtes des quelque
chose les enquêteurs pensent avoir
affaire à deux des trois membres du
commando de thé a soupçonné d'avoir tué
deux gardes civils espagnols samedi à
cap breton
l'homme arrêté pourrait être à cerner
goa lopez des harmensyah un cadre
présumé de thé à la femme n'a pas encore
été identifié peu après leur
interpellation
la justice a annoncé le décès de fernand
d'autres apéros blázquez le garde civil
a succombé à ses blessures à l'hôpital
de bayonne
il avait 23 ans raul centeno 24 ans
avait lui été tué sur le coup samedi les
deux gardes civils espagnols étaient
désarmés
quand on leur a tiré dessus voilà retour
maintenant sur cette histoire
franco-algérienne décidément brûlante
on retrouve le grand absent d'abord de
ce voyage présidentiel bonsoir enrico
macias
né en algérie vous avez vécu en algérie
et tout ce qui s'est passé là-bas vous
tient très à coeur
d'abord est-ce que nicolas sarkozy
aurait dû selon vous présenter des
excuses pour la colonisation n'ont
absolument pas et je suis catégorique
quand il y a quelque chose qui s'est
passé dans l'histoire entre deux pays
eh bien
on ne présente pas des excuses parce que
des deux côtés alors il faudrait sans
arrêt qu'il y ait des excuses réciproque
pour tout ce qui a été fait des deux
côtés
bon c'est vrai que il ya eu les deux ont
assez payé comme ça donc maintenant je
crois que le voyage de nicolas sarkozy
s'est inscrit dans dans la
réconciliation entre les deux pays et
surtout pour la création de l'union de
la méditerranée
moi je le vois comme ça et je trouve que
c'est formidable que son voyage est très
réussi alors vous avez été déclaré
persona non grata
côté algérien par le musée juif même si
ça n'a pas été dit explicitement mais
tout le monde a compris ça vous êtes
resté silencieux jusqu'à présent
quel est votre sentiment sur cette
situation d'abord j'ai pas voulu
m'exprimer pour ne pas polluer le voyage
de nicolas sarkozy
mon cas personnel n'est pas du tout
important mais alors pas du tout ce qui
compte le plus pour moi c'est l'histoire
entre la france et l'algérie et surtout
surtout la reconnaissance des pieds
noirs des harkis des berbères du peuple
algérien qui se sont frustrés et je
trouve que les dirigeants algériens
auront appris par le message de nicolas
sarkozy qui ne faut pas se servir de
cette maladie qu'est l'exclusion et le
racisme et l'antisémitisme et
l'islamophobie
alors vous êtes justement à l'elysée où
vous avez assisté à ce discours c'est
parole de nicolas sarkozy de la france
envers les harkis étaient suffisantes ce
soir on a eu le sentiment qu'ils
attendaient plus on attend toujours plus
mais moi ce que je veux ce que je peux
dire c'est que le avant avant le
d'entendre le discours de ce soir à
l'elysée j'étais vraiment très déçu du
fait que je ne sois pas aller surtout
quand j'ai vu nicolas sarkozy ce matin à
constantine
quand il a parlé a consenti dans ma
ville natale mais quand j'ai pas quand
j'ai entendu le président je sois parler
pour les harkis pour les pieds noirs
quand il a fait ce geste
dès son retour d'algérie pour rassurer
tous les enfants d'algérie
moi je trouve que j'ai changé d'avis je
crois que je suis sur le chemin de
partir en algérie
le président me l'a dit lui même il là
il m'a donné beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de d'espérance puisqu'il est parlé avec
les autorités algériennes et en
particulier avec le président bouteflika
qui j'espère cette fois ci tiendra
parole merci enrico macias d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce soir
l'économie on en sait davantage sur le
système du bonus malus qui doit
encourager vous le savez les voitures
propres
la prime à l'achat ira jusqu'à 1000
euros elle est applicable dès
aujourd'hui la taxe réservé aux
véhicules les plus polluants israël
jusqu'à 2600 euros le dispositif devrait
être neutre pour les finances publiques
la prime à la casse elle reste très
limité si explications nicolas
chateauneuf david fosse à favoriser les
véhicules les plus propres au détriment
des plus polluants c'était une des
promesses du grenelle de l'environnement
un système de bonus malus qui devrait
s'appliquer une seule fois pour les
voitures neuves à l'immatriculation les
malus ne seront appliqués qu'au 1er
janvier
le bonus est valable dès aujourd'hui les
conducteurs eux se sont déjà fait leur
opinion mais la prochaine
moins polluants je reçois un enfant pour
qui si vous dites ça parce que vous
auriez un bonus ah oui des robien et
bien cela dépend des modèles pour cette
voiture de ville un nouvel acheteur
touchera un bonus de 700 euros pour
cette berline par contre il sera
pénalisé de 750 euros
quant aux propriétaires de ce gros 4 4
il devra débourser 2600 euros de plus le
maximum en fait le dispositif est
graduelle les bonus par exemple
s'échelonnent de 200 à 1000 euros pour
les véhicules les moins polluants
chez les concessionnaires on anticipe
déjà les demandes des futurs clients
auront quand même des clients qui sont
déjà en train d' écologie qui ne vont
pas régulièrement
maintenant il va être beaucoup plus
difficile d'expliquer sur une voiture
j'irai familiale qui en effet il y à un
malus
le dispositif prévoit enfin une prime à
la casse pour les voitures de plus de 15
ans lors de l'achat simultané d'une
voiture peu polluante
ce super bonus sera de 300 euros
les propos de pouvoir d'achat il faut
s'attendre à une hausse du prix du gaz
au 1er janvier gaz de france souhaite
une augmentation des tarifs de 5 à 6%
pour les particuliers de 10% pour les
entreprises selon le journal la tribune
c'est le gouvernement qui tranchera il
faut signaler que contrairement à ce que
l'on a tendance à penser les prix du gaz
n'ont pas bougé depuis 18 mois
la semaine dernière on en a beaucoup
parlé le gouvernement annonçait des
mesures pour le pouvoir d'achat axé sur
le travail
une catégorie s'estiment oubliés et elle
regroupe tout de même plus de 13
millions de personnes
il s'agit des retraités qui négocie en
ce moment la revalorisation des pensions
sophie brune sylvain gauthier marie
claire koch surveille de près ses
comptes
lorsqu'elle a pris sa retraite en 98
après avoir travaillé dans la confection
elle touche et 1000 euros par mois dix
ans plus tard sa pension n'a progressé
que de 2 200 euros
il ya beaucoup de choses que j'ai que je
supprime et les sorties de l'été or le
cinéma coiffeur bon match et veulent une
fois tous les deux mois maintenant chant
sûr j'attends le solde le loyer le
chauffage et la mutuelle représente
presque la moitié de son budget alors
les dépenses de santé sont presque un
luxe
j'étais obligé de prendre un prêt
ce que je devais changer de lunettes et
je pouvais plus j'avais plus l'argent
pour payer pour payer mon lunettes
j'avoue aussi fallait je prends nouvelle
une prothèse a fallu que ray j'emprunte
et pourtant cette retraitée ne fait pas
partie des plus mal loties sans les
retraites complémentaires la pension
moyenne dans le régime général est passé
de 476 à 581 euros mensuels en dix ans
environ 20% d'augmentation à peu près
autant que l'inflation
cela signifie une quasi stagnation du
pouvoir d'achat et tour les syndicats
malgré le plan de nicolas sarkozy ça ne
va pas s'arranger
nous sommes complètement maltraités
parce qu'il n'a pas dit un mot sur les
retraites pas un seul mot sur le
retraité son tube pour 2008 le
gouvernement a prévu de revaloriser les
pensions d'un peu plus d'un pour cent
justice la cour d'assises de paris
accède finalement la demande d' yvan
colonna et de ses avocats elle se
déplacera bien en corse à ajaccio sur
les lieux où le préfet erignac a été
assassiné ce sera sans doute ce week-end
il ne s'agira pas d'une reconstitution
mais d'un simple transport pour
réexaminer les circonstances du crime
c'est une procédure assez rare la cour
veut désamorcer semble-t-il toute
critique sur le respect des droits de la
défense images signées jean marc
nouknouk un moment de grandes vérités et
d'humanité c'est ainsi qu'un avocat a
commenté le tournant qui s'est produit
aujourd'hui au procès des agresseurs de
mama galedou pour la première fois l'un
des mineurs accusés est passé aux aveux
il a reconnu être l'incendiaire du bus
dans lequel la jeune femme a failli
perdre la vie sur place à aix en
provence stéphane despinoy benoît
jourdain
la maman de l'un des six accusés sort
effondré à la barre elle vient de
demander à son fils dit la vérité dit si
c'est toi c'est moi répond t-il coup de
théâtre dans le huis clos de la cour
d'assises dès mineurs les aveux ont été
exprimées
par eddie mendil au moment où sa mère
est venue à la barre pour lui demander
de dire la vérité et il ya eu un échange
de regards très intense il vient donc de
vous et que c'est lui qui a jeté le
mouchoir enflammé dans le bus 32
s'attendent se refuse à y croire la
vérité est là voulu couvrir et quelqu'un
voilà la voulu couvrir quelqu'un le
quelqu'un je sais pas voilà mais c'est
pas lui la journée a été marquée par le
témoignage émouvant de la maman de mama
galedou son frère lui aussi a tenu à
interpeller les prévenus en leur
demandant de le regarder dans les yeux
et de dire la vérité
l'un des six a donc craqué sur l'entamé
c'est parce qu'il croit qu'il ya plus
personne
et comme dit à l'extérieur du bus crois
que je crois qu'il fera pas de victimes
et c'est vrai que il est terriblement
désolé ce soir-là familiale et doux à la
réponse qu'elle attendait elle sait qui
a mis le feu aux bulls un début de
vérité la loi du silence a en fait été
brisées en bref nicolas sarkozy réserve
sa réponse après la proposition de la
colombie il n'exclut pas un voyage sur
place pour discuter avec les rebelles
des farc qui détiennent d'ingrid
betancourt mais ne souhaite pas se
précipiter plusieurs médiations déjà
échoué et l'elysée ne veux pas être
instrumentalisé par bogota
pendant ce temps vous le voyez une
nouvelle photo d'ingrid betancourt a été
affichée à l'hôtel de ville de paris 1-2
la vidéo où l'on découvre l'otage
amaigri et affaibli des images signées
alain du bas toujours à l'étranger
direction l'afrique maintenant et plus
précisément la somalie ce pays situé
tout à l'est du continent un peu plus
grand que la france est peuplée de 8
millions d'habitants est livrée aux
chefs de guerre depuis plus de 15 ans la
guerre civile en a fait l'un des
territoires les plus pauvres de la
planète
et depuis plusieurs mois les bateaux de
ravitaillement humanitaire sont pillées
par des pirates 25 attaques depuis le
début de l'année du coup l'armée
française a décidé d'accompagner les
navires
nos envoyés spéciaux ont pu monter à
bord reportage dominique derda frédéric
ranque
cette distribution de nourriture il ya
longtemps qu'il attendait 3 semaines
pour qu'un camion n'était venu jusqu'au
camp de déplacés de bufo à une centaine
de kilomètres de mogadiscio
apporter à ceux qui ont fui les combats
qui font rage dans la capitale
de quoi tenir encore un peu non
seulement on a tout perdu mais dans les
magasins il n'y a rien non plus avec la
sécheresse qu'on a eu cette année les
champs n'ont rien donné pour subvenir
aux besoins du million de personnes
chassées de chez elles par la guerre
civile
les nations unies doivent acheminer pas
moins de cent mille tonnes de nourriture
par an et c'est par la mère qu'elle les
transporte
mais la mer au large de la somalie est
infestée de pirates qui cette année ont
détourné pas moins de 25 navires de
commerce des bandits qui pourrait bien
désormais y réfléchir à deux fois avant
de s'en prendre à ceux affrété par le
pam le programme alimentaire mondial ces
hommes sont des commandos de marine ils
vont prendre place à bord des deux
cargos qui transporte trois mille sept
cent cinquante tonnes de vivres
derrière eux un aviso de la marine
nationale française un bateau de guerre
puissamment armés partie de mombasa au
kenya
à l'aller comme au retour il suit et
protège les navires du pam
les deux bâtiments qu'on escorte ont
déjà été piraté par par le passé le
siège no une fois l'heureuse m
deux fois dont une fois en 2007 en début
d'année effectivement le programme
alimentaire mondial a aujourd'hui
beaucoup de mal à trouver des armateurs
très envoyer leur bateau en somalie avec
de tels enjeux gardien le voyage on s'en
doute s'est déroulée sans le moindre
incident et ce n'est pas pour déplaire à
l'équipage du cem zuma zuma le chef
mécanicien a déjà été pris en otage
c'était il ya deux ans ça a duré trois
mois
pourtant depuis il a repris la mer ces
derniers temps dans la marine marchande
il n'y a plus beaucoup de travail
les gens se demandent s'ils doivent
risquer leur vie
ou bien rester à la maison sans pouvoir
nourrir leurs familles ou payer l'école
de leurs enfants au large de mercato le
cmes l'eau et le rosen viennent de jeter
l'ancré on se hâte de décharger la
précieuse cargaison sur la plage ils
sont des centaines venus prêter
main-forte une véritable fourmilière
les marins français à quelques milles de
là attendent la fin des opérations pour
retourner au kenya leur mission dans
l'océan indien ne doit durer que deux
mois pour escorter les convois jusqu'ici
la france espère convaincre d'autres
nations de prendre la relève le royaume
uni l'allemagne et pourquoi pas le
danemark l'été dernier en effet un cargo
danois était détourné par des pirates au
large de la somalie
il en a coûté à l'armateur plus d'un
million d'euros pour récupérer son
navire et son équipage toujours à
l'étranger les nouvelles méthodes de
contrôle des chômeurs en grande bretagne
la comparaison est intéressante car vous
le savez la france peut revoir tout le
système en fusionnant l'anpe et l'unedic
le projet sera présenté demain en
conseil des ministres là-bas à londres
les vérifications vont très loin les
services sociaux traque le travail au
noir et les deux demandeurs d'emploi
sont même soumis à des détecteurs de
mensonges
reportage maryse burgot dominique
marault tél impossible de se soustraire
à ce rendez vous toutes les deux
semaines james graphique de sans emploi
vient qui s'y rendre des comptes
il a certes des droits 82 euros par
semaine tarif unique pour tout le monde
que l'on soit ex pdg ou ex ouvriers mais
il a surtout des devoirs
cette conseillère va donc lui demander
des justificatifs prouvant qu'ils
cherchent vraiment du travail
s'il n'a pas cherché du travail pendant
les quinze jours précédant les
allocations sont suspendus et c'est bien
ce qui pourrait arriver à james s'il
continue à jouer les dilettantes
c'est vrai que je ne cherche pas
vraiment je manque un peu d'énergie en
ce moment
les chômeurs strictement encadrée et
même parfois tractées cette campagne
diffusée sur les télévisions prévient
les faux chômeurs ceux qui par exemple
le travail au noir tout en touchant une
allocation seront poursuivis en justice
et pour traquer les tricheurs les
britanniques vont encore plus loin ici
on appelle par téléphone les
bénéficiaires d'allocations logement et
on vérifie grâce à un détecteur de
mensonges qui lui est bien la vérité et
dans quelques semaines cette méthode
sera aussi utilisée pour détecter les
faux chômeurs
grâce à ce logiciel cet employé analyse
les variations de la voix de son
interlocuteur lorsque les lettres h&r
apparaissent cela veut dire que le
risque est très haut d'avoir à faire un
menteur qui trichent pour obtenir des
allocations
un système déjà utilisé par les
compagnies d'assurance
bientôt les chômeurs eux aussi ils
seront soumis retour en france avec des
contestations à villiers-le-bel suite à
la décision de la police de distribuer
des tracts proposant une rémunération en
échange de toute information importante
sur les fauteurs de troubles les élus
locaux par le même de prime à la
délation reportage arnault compte lionel
langlade dans ce hall d'immeuble il
reste encore quelques exemplaires de
l'appel à témoins pour retrouver les
auteurs des coups de feu
quatre mille tracts comme celui ci ont
été glissés par la police dans les
boîtes aux lettres une en tête du
ministère de l'intérieur un numéro vert
et cette dernière phrase tout élément
susceptible de faire avancer l'enquêté
pourra faire l'objet d'une rémunération
cette initiative fait parler dans la
cité certains habitants doutent de son
utilité
je pense pas que j'en arrive à ça veut
dire oui c'est lui ou c'est lui est-ce
que c'est des gens vous connaissez
je connais la radio militante génération
88 s'est rebaptisé ce matin par dérision
génération délation voilà je vais
intervenir par rapport à ce qui se passe
là les tracts ou un truc qui me fait
délirer c'est qu'apparemment ils
envoient des tracts parce que des flics
sont fait tirer dessus bon on est
d'accord les choses qui se font pas
certains élus aussi sont défavorables à
la méthode de la police ont fait un
appel à témoins pour les blessures
infligées aux policiers et qu'on ne fait
pas dans le même tract un appel à
témoins pour les personnes qui auraient
été qui aurait été présente lors de la
survenue de l'accident la police elle
justifie son initiative
la démarche est unique parce que les
événements sont complètement inhabituel
c'est la première fois que 55 policiers
dans le cadre de l'opération de maintien
de l'ordre sont blessés par balles alors
qu'une quinzaine d'autres par
projectiles par planck plusieurs
dizaines d'appels ont déjà été reçus par
la police judiciaire de versailles pour
le moment très peu seraient exploitables
c'est aujourd'hui que le sénat devait
voter définitivement le budget du
ministère de l'intérieur et donc bien
sûr les moyens de la police à l'heure de
l'adn et des méthodes scientifiques nous
avons voulu savoir ce qu'était le
travail et les méthodes de la brigade
criminelle le fameux 36 quai des
orfèvres chose très rare vous allez
assister aux premières loges à toutes
les étapes d'une enquête de la
découverte du corps à l'arrestation des
coupables et vous rendre compte que loin
des hautes technologies ce métier
d'enquêteur est d'abord une affaire de
flers et de travail d'équipé
voici ce document il est signé audrey
goutard mathias second d'habitude ici
les promeneurs et les joggeurs se
croisent le long du canal
mais cet après midi tout est différent
un cadavre vient d'être repêché dans
l'eau
en raison du d'une alliance
la victime a été étranglée puis égorgée
ici est mis dans le canal juste à
l'aplomb le fils électriques
et voici larmes qui a servi à étrangler
la négativement qui a été retrouvé sur
les lieux du crime
donc c'est un premier témoin est déjà un
élément
j'ai vu une voiture qui était garée là
avec une personne qui était elle était
au volant ou ici base de la pensée
unique
je sais que c'est un scenic avec des
espèces de vautours
les événements se précipitent au
téléphone une femme recherche son mari
il a disparu ce matin à l'aube alors
qu'il partait au travail semblerait
qu'il s'agisse de la personne qu'on
vient de
retrouvé dans le canal rapport à
l'identité aux éléments qu'elle donne
même voiture même prénom que dans
l'alliance la victime identifiée
il faut prévenir sa famille c'est en
général un moment assez difficile parce
qu'il faut aller annoncer une nouvelle
absolument dramatique à quelqu'un qui
s'attend à tout sauf à ça une partie de
la nuit les policiers vont soutenir mais
aussi discrètement questionner la
famille car dans la majorité des
affaires de meurtres les auteurs sont
des proches des victimes le lendemain au
36 quai des orfèvres les policiers en
savent déjà plus
le mort est un jeune père de famille un
boulanger qui n'a jamais eu de problèmes
avec la justice
les policiers ont aussi appris que sa
carte bancaire a été utilisée après le
meurtre pour se voir il faut interroger
les banques responsables
mais voilà on est samedi et pas de
responsable et alors vous travailler le
week-end vous fait quoi là le si vous
répondez pas aux demandes d'accord au
revoir donc jamais raccroché au nez
je veillais faudra attendre 48 heures
une réponse de la banque
même pour la brigade criminelle lundi
matin on sait maintenant chez qui la
carte a servi
voyez nous les décrire un peu dur oui je
sais je peux vous dire ils sont très
jeunes enfin je moi je leur donne vingt
ans nous allons tour quoi ça peut 19 22
ans face au dollar
les deux hommes ont acheté un blouson et
des pizzas
juste après le meurtre finir voilà il
est ne prendre leur pizza on les voit se
servir de la carte de la victime
il a le déjà le blouson il a lancé c'est
très bon comme truc très bon oui mais
pas encore suffisant pour identifier les
deux hommes s'étant fait un coup de
pouce du destin qui fait basculer
l'enquète cet homme est arrêté au volant
d'une voiture volée celle de la victime
c'est un ancien collègue du boulanger il
a 25 ans à peine et dans son passé juste
une affaire de vol il reconnaît qu'il
était là mais accuse un autre du meurtre
il être karim va étrangler par tous les
moyens
trouver ou à porter avec yann houssier
tu sais pas les policiers n'y crois pas
dit non mais c'est pour ça c'est
physique
celui-ci mais t'es quoi c'est pourquoi
ils peuvent très bien se voir fermer ils
décident de hausser le ton elle permet
de chaque équation ne fait pas une
réforme annoncée donc qu'une zone est
censuré fort tu fuis d'un regard
réuniront pour voir pourquoi tu m'as
menti à quoi à quoi sur le fait que tu
as et rendez michael de tes propres
mains la nouvelle stratégie paye deux
heures plus tard d'accord et là est ce
que tu as fait j'ai coupé j'ai loupé
michael georgy des deux coaches sa
marathon parce que c'est un peu fatigant
même psychologiquement c'est fatiguant
de garder la patience de faire venir la
personne parce qu'elle doit dire
finalement
l'adn a révolutionné la police mais
finalement les enquêteurs de la brigade
criminelle s'appuie toujours sur les
mêmes fondamentaux la recherche de
témoignages le recrutement des indices
les déductions une matière humaine
fragile les policiers le savent aussi
les aveux ça ne suffit pas il faut
multiplier les éléments de preuve on
demande à ces commerçants chez qui la
carte a été utilisée d'identifier le
suspect s'appelle le tapissage
fragilité de la mémoire seuls deux
témoins sur quatre le désignant c'est au
tour du complice présumé d'être arrêté
un boulanger de 23 ans connu pour de
petits délits
au bout de quatre heures d'audition il
lui aussi avoue sa participation au
meurtre
mais apparemment il ne comprend pas la
gravité de son geste
on a besoin de la résection jeu là là
c'est sûr
oui
flatté à peu près assuré d'aller en
prison en sortant j pourquoi ont-ils tué
les suspect connaissait bien la victime
là deux tournées même autour de la femme
du boulanger jalousie envie appât du
gain en cinq jours les policiers ont
résolu la faire mais ce sera aux juges
d'en comprendre les causes
quant au suspect il encourt la réclusion
à perpétuité
la brigade criminelle considérée comme
une unité d'élite cette retraite une
trentaine d'affaires de ce genre par
année en région parisienne
l'environnement la conférence de bali
est réuni depuis quelques jours pour
réfléchir aux actions à mener contre le
changement climatique
parmi les effets directement visible le
dépérissement des coraux qui est
également il faut le dire la conséquence
de la pêche à la dynamite une expérience
encourageante est en cours basée sur un
outil l'électricité explications agnès
monteux on les appelle les forêts
tropicales sous marine
six cent mille kilomètres carrés de
coraux qui abrite des centaines de
milliers d'espèces dans le monde entier
mais de cette merveille on est en train
de passer à ça des coraux blanchi sans
couleur réchauffement climatique pêche
trop brutale
c'est fragile animaux meurent une
catastrophe écologique contre laquelle
certains scientifiques pensent avoir
trouvé une parade
ces capteurs solaires installées au
large de ben ali il transport de
l'électricité sous l'eau jusque dans ses
pépinières d armature métallique
grillagé sur lesquels des débris de
coraux ont été installés traversé par un
faible courant il se met à pousser vite
très vite
trois à quatre fois plus rapidement que
dans des conditions naturelles notre
système rend l'eau moins acide et c'est
ce qui provoque chimiquement la
croissance du calcaire des coraux
incroyable il devient même plus
résistants face au réchauffement ou
maladie bien sûr impossible d'imaginer
installé ses nurserie partout les coraux
sont menacés mais localement
ça permettrait de faire prospérer tout
un univers
de donner à manger aux pêcheurs et de
faire venir les touristes
il a 50 ans il est français ingénieur et
colonels et il s'apprête à passer deux
mois et demi dans l'espace le
spationaute léopold eyharts se prépare à
décoller demain à bord de la navette
spatiale
il va avec d'autres arrimer le premier
laboratoire européen de recherche à la
station spatiale internationale
nicolas chateauneuf jean-marie le
quartier l'ont rencontré il a observé
les salamandres se tortiller dans
l'espace
il a passé des heures à flotter avec des
électrodes sur le corps il a bu de
drôles de mixtures sous vide
il a même fait du vélo en apesanteur
aujourd'hui léopold eyharts tu s'apprête
à retourner dans l'espace
dix ans après son vol avant de venir le
voilà prêt à poser le pied dans la
station spatiale internationale
donc on a la possibilité depuis le sceau
de contrôler la confidence il ya
quelques semaines nous l'avions suivi au
centre d'entraînement des astronautes de
cologne c'était l'heure des dernières
répétitions sur une réplique exacte de
la station la même que celle qui flotte
à 400km dessus de nos têtes
le désordre en moi beaucoup plus gros
sa mission mettre en route le
laboratoire européen columbus ce que
vous pouvez voir ici c'est donc le
volume dans son ensemble avec toutes les
installations techniques et layrac
scientifiques qui vont permettre donc
d'effectuer du travail à bord et aussi
de vivre deux mois et demi dans la
station a travaillé à dormir dans un
petit coin spécialement aménagée oncle a
surtout besoin d'un volume
qui est une isolation sonore sur tout et
puis où on peut avoir ses petites
affaires personnelles sans que tout
s'envole qui peu partout depuis plus
d'un an et demi l'ancien pilote de
chasse qui se prépare et suis aux états
unis un entraînement de haut niveau
tout cela pour embarquer à bord de la
navette américaine atlantis avec ses six
co équipier et le laboratoire columbus
mais avant il y à ce décollage à risque
quand je regarde un vaisseau spatial
partir j'ai prise de peur que quand je
mange je suis moi même à l'intérieur
donc je pense surtout à ma famille pour
la deuxième fois de sa vie léopold
eyharts enfile donc la combinaison de
l'astronaute avec devant lui de longues
semaines de travail en apesanteur mais
son bureau à lui à une vue imprenable
sur la terre
si les mains avec la sortie du premier
volet à demain d'une nouvelle saga
ésotérique adapté d'un roman à succès un
peu sur le modèle de la rippe auteurs le
film s'appelle à la croisée des mondes
la boussole d'or avec notamment nicole
kidman et eva green
emmanuel lambert didier d'adapter un
roman fantastique à succès
hollywood maîtrise bien cette mécanique
après le seigneur des anneaux et ses
milliards de dollars de recettes
harry potter et déjà cinq films voici à
la croisée des mondes très certainement
la nouvelle poule aux oeufs d'or
ici chacun possède un double animal son
âme en quelque sorte
allons-nous voir l'enfant oui je le
crois
et dans ce monde qui ressemble au nôtre
le magisterium une organisation secrète
veut contrôler le destin de tous les
autres à des personnes savent ce qui est
bien pour elle et d'autres personnes non
cela dit ils ne le disent pas aux gens
de ta son méchant tu vois il ya de la
magie tous à des créatures assez
inhabituel mais a aussi beaucoup de de
rien à côté philosophique très spirituel
c'est un coin lira une jeune orpheline
se voit confier la boussole d'or qui
dévoile l'avenir la saq est retrouvé des
centaines d'enfants enlevés mystérieuse
mange la jeune actrice dakota blue
richards d' était patente et pourtant
c'est son premier film
la difficulté pour elle donnait la
réplique à un ours valeureux grâce aux
effets spéciaux mais plutôt inexpressif
lors du tournage jusqu'à ce que tu
l'obtiennent la victoire vous devez
réfléchir deux fois plus mal c'est
difficile il faut jouer et faire
semblant que l'ours est vraiment devant
vous l'auteur du livre philip pullman a
supplié nicole kidman en 95 il a écrit
ce rôle en pensant à elle
c'est assez embarrassant pour moi mais
en même temps c'est très flatteur
il m'a s'invite à la croisée des mondes
est une réussite mais pour connaître le
fin mot de l'histoire il faudra
patienter deux autres films sont en
préparation pour les plus impatients les
1030 pages du roman se dévore très
facilement
avant de refermer cette édition je vous
en rappelle l'un des principaux titres
le geste de la république alors qu'on
voyait antoine deneriaz alors on va
peut-être y revenir aux descendeurs
champion olympique l'an dernier qui a
annoncé aujourd'hui sa retraite à 31 ans
seulement il faut dire qu'il avait fait
une chute terrible
l'an passé il a avoué que depuis il
connaissait la peur je vous rappelle
donc l'un des principaux titres de cette
édition le geste de nicolas sarkozy
envers les harkis la france leur doit à
réparation indique le président la
république de retour d'alger réparation
pour les fautes qui ont été commises
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko 20h50 johnny chante pour
vous c'est un spécial taratata présentée
par nagui
à demain
de l'info en continu c'est aussi sur
france 2 points